we know that a function is something
that can take a set of numbers and take
each of those numbers and map them to
another set of numbers
so if i start with a set of numbers
so i'm going to put those here under x
so the set of numbers that i can input
into a function or the set of numbers
for which a function is defined that we
call a domain we've seen that before and
so we could try out different values in
the domain and let's say that this right
over here this graph we can view is
something of a function definition so if
x is equal to zero
as x is equal to zero what does this
graph is tell what does this graph tell
us that f of x is going to be
it tells us that f of x is going to be
equal to
negative eight
fair enough it took zero as an input and
it mapped it to one value to negative
eight
now if x is equal to
two
what does this function map it to well f
of x is
negative six negative six well that's
all fine it's just taking this value and
it's mapping it to negative six
now what if x were
what if x were negative two
if x were negative two
it also maps it to negative six
now this is all okay for a function as
long as when you give it a value it can
spit out of it it knows which value to
spit out you have a legitimate function
you could have two inputs mapped to the
same value just like we had over here
another way to think about this is if
you have your domain
and then you have your range so this is
the set of all the valid inputs into
your function and then the range and the
way we talk about range is really the
image this is a set of all of the valid
outputs of your function for each of all
of these valid inputs so this is your
domain
domain
and this is your range
what we just saw over here is that the 2
maps to
negative 6
negative 6 and that the negative 2
negative 2 also
maps to negative 6 which once again it's
completely fine for a function you would
have an issue this would no longer be a
function if two could map to two
different values if two could map to
negative six
or
if two could map to negative six or say
seven
now then this is getting weird now this
is an ever this is no longer a function
where you can get two possible values
being outputted for a given input but
that's not what's happening right now so
just what we've drawn over here this
looks like a function it's completely
legitimate and one of the tests that
people make sure that for each input you
only have one output it's often called
the vertical line test where you take a
vertical line you say okay does it
intersect the graph of the function only
once because that says well for each
value of x do you only have one possible
value of your function one possible
value of y is equal to f of x and so
this is clearly a function
now the next question is is it an
invertible
because in order for a function to be
invertible you should be able to define
a function that maps the other way
so you should be able to take
you should be able to take a
let's call it a y
equals f of x you should be able to take
one of those
and then
apply your inverse function to it
apply your inverse function and get the
x that would give you that y so you
should that that should give you
so you should be able to get
x should be the inverse so it should map
the other way so what am i talking about
well
if you input a negative eight
if you input a negative eight well then
that should go to a zero it's going the
other way it's going the other way the
inverse function instead of mapping from
the function maps from zero to negative
eight the inverse function will map from
negative eight will map from negative
eight to zero the input into the
function that you would have had to get
to get to negative eight and we call
that f inverse so we could say f inverse
of negative 8 should be f inverse of
negative 8 should be 0 and i could even
write this i could write this as f
inverse of negative 8 should be equal to
0.
but then we start seeing something
interesting because the inverse has to
be has to be a function in its own right
and if we say well okay what should f
inverse of negative 6 be
and you say well g there's two ways to
get to negative 6 for the function you
could go from 2 or negative 2. so the f
inverse if you're trying to do it you
say maybe it's 2 or it's negative 2.
well then f inverse wouldn't be a
function if one input maps to multiple
outputs so this isn't okay so when you
see something like this when you have a
function that where you have two of its
inputs mapping to the same output
you no longer have an invertible
function so this one as it's defined
right over here is not invertible
not
it is not invertible and why isn't it
invertible because you have two
different values mapping to the same f
of x and this or actually you have that
happening multiple times two
and
negative two both map to six
they both map to six
three
and
three and negative three both map to the
same value in fact this keeps happening
over and over and over again
and so you can start to see well maybe
there's a test for whether something is
invertible and just as we have the
vertical line test for a uh to see if
something can be a function we can do a
horizontal line test to see if it is
invertible and this one clearly fails
that because with the horizontal line
you can see that multiple x values
multiple x values can map to the same f
of x value to the same if we say that
you know this is the graph of if you say
this is the graph of y is equal to f of
x they're mapping to the same y value if
they're mapped to the same y value then
when you try to invert it that y value
will map to two different x values and
so that the inverse or this thing that
you're trying to construct as an inverse
would no longer be a function so this
thing isn't invertible but then it gives
us a question can we restrict can we
restrict this function in some way can
we restrict the domain of this function
in some way so that it could be
invertible and one other way to think
about it could we restrict this function
in a way in some way so it passes this
horizontal line test
well one way that we could restrict this
function one way that we could restrict
this function
is if we restricted it only to
the right two quadrants or only to the
left two quadrants so for example if you
restricted this function to
let's say the domain going from zero to
actually you could go to infinity you
could go to infinity if you like
then all of a sudden the only stuff that
you would have in your function the only
part of your function that would be if
you restricted to this domain would be
this side right over here and if you
only have one side of this parabola
of this of this curve then it would pass
the horizontal line test and it would be
invertible and the reason why it passes
it because then you have a one-to-one
mapping for each
each each y value is being mapped to by
only one x value by a unique x value so
you could restrict in that way or you
could restrict in other ways you could
restrict from you could restrict from
negative infinity negative infinity to
zero i wrote that infinity in a weird
way you could restrict from negative
infinity to zero you could restrict from
negative three to negative two if you
restricted from negative three to
negative two the only part of your
function you would see is this part
right over here which would pass your
horizontal line test and your vertical
line test and so it's a legitimate
function and it would be
invertible so hopefully that gives you a
little bit more sense of what
invertibility means or
or how you can test for it and how you
can restrict the domain of a function so
that you can take a non-invertible
function a non-invertible function and
turn it into an invertible one